Right now we've learned that Donald Trump's
personal lawyer, Rudy Giuliani is back in
Ukraine right now, right?
He's in Ukraine right now and what is Rudy
doing back in Ukraine?
He is talking once again, former prosecutors
that were part of how this entire scandal
started in the first place.
Look at what Giuliani is doing as per the
New York times Tuesday.
He met with a former Ukrainian prosecutor
in Budapest.
This is URI loot Sanko that name.
If you've been watching the impeachment inquiry
hearings should ring a bell because it has
come up dozens of times during those hearings.
Wednesday he went to Kiev or Kieve as we are
now told is the Ukrainian pronunciation.
Went to Kiev, Ukraine to meet with more Ukrainian
prosecutors including the infamous Victor
Shoken who is almost at the center of this
entire controversy.
The reason why Rudy is back in the region,
back in Ukraine, meeting with these people
now he's supposedly gathering information
to be part of a documentary series for a right
wing media outlet meant to promote Trump and
to defend Trump against the case for impeachment.
What a convenient trip for Rudy Giuliani,
right?
Imagine you're running impeachment hearings
centered around Trump and his associates using
Ukraine to try to smear Joe Biden in a bribery
extortion scandal and you say, okay, you know
who we should really bring in.
Let's bring in Rudy Giuliani.
He should testify.
Let's get in touch with Rudy.
We did.
You know what?
Turns out he can't come to the hearings because
he's in Ukraine right now, meeting with the
exact same people, asking for information
that can be used in a right wing media piece
to argue that there is no case for impeachment
against Donald Trump hearings about Rudy possibly
committing or organizing crimes to help the
president.
Sorry, he can't make it.
He's tied up back in Ukraine, possibly committing
crimes or organizing crimes to help the president
under the guise of he's now a TV producer.
I guess working on some right wing media.
Um, a documentary meant to defend Donald Trump.
And you know what?
We really shouldn't be surprised by this.
Remember that when about, I think it was six
months ago, Donald Trump was interviewed by
George Stephanopoulos on ABC news and George
Stephanopoulos said to him, mr president,
after everything that's happened with Russia
after the Mueller probe this, that, all this
different stuff, if Russia came to you with
a dirt on opponents for 2020 or China came
to you with dirt on opponents for 2020, would
you go to the FBI or would you, would you
accept it?
And Trump said, yeah, I did.
At least look into it.
Go to the FBI now, probably not.
But I would at least look into what they were
bringing me.
And if I were them, if I was as immoral as
they are, I would probably be doing the same
thing because there have been no consequences
if you are Trump and you see, well, so far
I've gotten away with everything.
Sure.
Some of my old friends are in prison, but
I'm fine.
I would probably assume impeachments going
nowhere, likely accurate, and that means I
still have to figure out how to win.
In 2020 dispatch, Rudy back to Ukraine accepted
the dirt from Russia except they're from China.
At this point, I would hope that authorities
are watching Rudy Giuliani's movements, which
actually leads me to the next question.
Was it that great of an idea to have them
leave the country in the sense that his two
henchmen left Parness and Igor Fruman were
grabbed by authorities, arrested and indicted
as they were heading to Europe on one way,
plane tickets.
Giuliani might be close behind them or he
might never see consequences at all.
We just don't know.
Because when someone is in that second justice
system, when you're in the justice system
for what are effectively the American oligarchs,
not everybody else, you actually, uh, it becomes
harder to predict whether you'll, you'll ever
be held accountable for your actions at all.
So Rudy, back in Ukraine, it sounds stranger
than fiction, but that's the reality.
If this were a screenplay, it wouldn't be
believable.
It would be thrown onto the cutting room floor.
It happens to be real life.
Let me know what you think about Rudy and
Ukraine.
I'm on Twitter at D Pacman or leave
a [inaudible].
Why?
If
you're watching on YouTube